hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Rock of Ages and welcome
back shot leech how you do it I'm doing
good and today I guess we're gonna be
having another match of Rock of Ages and
this time I'm just a burger but yeah
yeah we don't know anything about that
because that video doesn't exist except
over on your channel so if you guys want
to see what happened my my recording
failed but in reality I just didn't want
my poor performance to be shown on
camera on my perspective so okay it all
comes down to this it all comes down to
one epic match of unbelievable
proportions to be able to kick you in
the tush and then you're gonna you're
gonna feel the rock up against your Vlad
well today we're going to witches
Sabbath okay I don't know what is it
nice troll face Rock what is a Sabbath
oh boy I don't know where I'm supposed
to be able to build stuff but here we go
I guess gee whiz school pretty mature
you put stuff in one direction one not
trust me reference uh-huh where where do
the where do the boulders oh okay
alright I think I know how to deal with
someone like you you deserve what you're
about to get in your face so why don't
you just eat a lot of this so I guess
this time I'm yeah yeah oh I think I
think maybe it's my turn to get out
there I hope you guys puppy puppy you
don't have much waiting for me I know
I know my mammoths are pretty and cried
well I don't know this map oh shoot
shootie shoot I'm a good ok god the
keyboard giving you some trouble there
it is but I've not barely get the
mammoths we're kind of initial there Oh
Nellie oh those mammoths are those just
elefantes ah good you blew up my boulder
Grillin wait I blew up your boulder like
blew up for good
oh I've never done that before Dole hey
hey come on you think your cows can beat
me huh honk oh boy oh I see you I see
you on the way
now you thinking you're it's too late
buddy boo it's ooh how's it feel mmm
feel good feel that you doing that you
do now I have more surprises for you and
I think again like I said in the
previous you're gonna probably like this
one I like a lot because I don't know if
you've ever not fair hang on hang on
hang on hang on hang on
all right yeah yeah what about what
about what about it what about it what
about it what about what's the deal
what's the deal what's up man what's up
uh-huh sure yeah okay that's what they
all say drug good oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh the probate shall not be
defeated oh yeah oh yeah it's too late
for you you know you might as well just
you know give up that's good did you
fall again good good good excellent as
should let me ask you a question how
does how does defeat taste does is it
good is it bitter is it like a like a
summer shanty you know this is a little
bit a little bit tap it on the tip salt
and that can I think I think your time
is that you're right boo ski oh this was
a mistake oh boy I made a bit of an
error there but it's alright someone Oh
made it made it nailed it oh boy
I am making it somewhere whoo what the
heck oh oh this is gonna be quite a fall
there's gotta be a bit thunderous oof
that did some doobage but you know
what's gonna do more damage
you know what's you know it's gonna do
more damage this point believe I knew
how to turn the figs canna I can't
exactly help you there I'm too busy
being amazing oh yeah I'm sorry to tell
you this what can i zoom in anymore
hey why can't I can I laugh at me a
cackling fool what the hell happened I
just what I have no idea what happened
but uh I'm just gonna hope for the best
oh hey oh I see intelligently placed a
mammoth in my path of a scenting victory
yeah that's how it works they got bombs
hey you get hit in the face and then I
win correct me if I'm wrong but I'm
pretty sure that's how it works
Oh No oh good thing I have midair
control on my Roarke hey hey hey hey
Patrick you uh you heard a your this
tale you heard the tale of Vlad via in
flattened by a bald boy oh that's so
anticlimactic incredible like screw Sh
with blood spurting everywhere I have no
idea but I think I think I won I'm
pretty sure I'll sing on flat down like
a pancake yes I mean it's a little bit
of solace in the end of your life
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching Thank You Patrick also
known as Schad leech if you want to see
a completely different video where the
tables might have been a little bit
turned in not my favor go check out
Patrick's channel over in the
description below it is Schad leech when
are you gonna get a custom URL I will
see we did this the same we did that the
same day we made the channel oh that's
true that's true we did do that anyways
like it doesn't show it but is there if
you do it's like charlie is there all
right I will put that link in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know your
thoughts down in the comments below and
as always I see what happened I won't
know inside the comments section if we
want a third match to decide who is the
better one the better bowler oh you are
barking up the wrong tree you are gonna
get your ass spanked all over the summer
field I have is that true yeah I've got
evidence that it's also not true for you
and true for me three to see which is
better troll face your smiley face
I think smiley face obviously wins but
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always we will see you in the
next video
bye-bye
[Music]